[Musique]
c'est une somme rondelette pour laquelle
l'état se porte garant pour le groupe
lagardère à 465 millions d'euros 10 pge
prêts garantis par l'état dirigé par
arnaud lagardère le groupe comporte
notamment les éditions hachette les
boutiques de gare ou aéroport rôle et où
plusieurs médias comme europe 1 paris
match le jdd et avec les pertes énormes
en 2020 arnaud lagardère peut pousser un
gros soupir de soulagement même si
groupe ne peut pas rembourser la note
l'état s'engage à payer la majeure
partie du crédit
80 % et par l'état entendait bien
évidemment vous et moi rue mais alors
comment le groupe lagardère en est-il
arrivé là
officiellement ce serait le coc vide
comme toujours il ya dans le dos suis là
bon c'est sûr que posséder un groupe de
boutiques d'aéroports et de gars quand
on n'a pas le droit de voyager ça doit
pas aider à booster un chiffre
d'affaires après avoir vu ses revenus
chuter de 55% au premier semestre
ce pan du groupe s'est effondré à la fin
de l'année de 66% pour plafonner à moins
de 400 millions d'euros de revenus à
côté de ça arnaud lagardère subit aussi
la fronde de deux actionnaires de son
groupe vincent bolloré et le groupe
vivendi son ancien pote et alliés et il
le fonds d'investissement ambert qui
remettent tous deux en cause la gestion
de fils héritier fils héritier qui au
passage a également une situation
personnelle pas très folichonne avec
plus de 160 millions d'euros de dettes
auprès du crédit agricole
pour ce qui est de ses entreprises en
tout cas reste à voir si ce fameux prêts
garantis par l'état suffira à donner
un peu d'humour groupe lagardère et à
ses salariés rien n'est moins sûr mais
en tout cas pour ses actionnaires bonne
nouvelle contracté à 1 p geo impose de
ne pas verser de dividende
uniquement l'année du prêt et ce même
s'il a été effectuée en toute fin
d'année 2020 comme c'est le cas ici
à défaut de sauver les emplois du groupe
lui il faudra se contenter de ça
[Musique]